avec plus de 32% des voix Jean-Luc
Mélenchon est arrivé en tête du premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle à
trappe pour les électeurs de cette ville
ancrée à gauche le report des voies
devrait se faire en faveur d'Emmanuel
Macron au premier tour j'avais voté
Benoît Hamon
pour François Fillon parce que c'est le
programme qui me plaisait le plus et
bien sûr que je vais voter pour Emmanuel
Macron parce que je suis contre le
programme d'extrême droite et de Marine
Le Pen donc j'ai même pas de doute au
premier tour j'ai voté François Fillon
au second tour je ne voterai pour
personne parce que je suis d'accord ni
je suis d'accord des deux candidats de
son côté le Front national souhaite
conqueraire certains électeurs fionistes
Versailles et je crois sincèrement à
l'instar de tous les gens du Parti
démocrate chrétien que le report va se
faire systématiquement dans le dernier
sondage au dos que ça Marine Le Pen est
crédité de 41% des voix derrière
Emmanuel Macron à 59% d'attention de
vote